make sure you have five for most
children a handful of nuts would be a
snack for Lena Barden they are a
treatment she has a life-threatening
allergy to peanuts but as part of a
clinical trial
doctors retrained her body to tolerate
them by starting with a tiny fraction of
one nut and increasing the dose over
several months she can now eat five nuts
a day without a reaction but she still
hates the taste Oh scoffing I hate the
smell and I hate the taste peanuts or
the main nuts that are in everything so
I might add much more things that they
may contain traces of peanuts so he'll
more safe in the biggest trial of its
kind doctors treated 99 children with a
severe allergy after several months 84%
were able to eat at least five peanuts
and 54% were able to eat ten this means
that children can go about their daily
lives and not worry about checking
labels at all because we don't really
believe that you could come across ten
peanuts or even five peanuts
accidentally the researchers at
Addenbrooke's Hospital in Cambridge are
planning to open a clinic for peanut
allergy sufferers more studies are
needed before the treatment can be
licensed and rolled out to the rest of
the country doctors a warning parent not
to give peanuts to children at home some
of the children in the study actually
had mild reactions to the peanut flour
one had a more severe reaction that
needed adrenaline this is a treatment
that can have side effects and it needs
to be given in hospital but for laners
mum shopping is now a little easier
treatment has brought peace of mind now
that she's becoming independent and she
wants to go out with her friends or she
goes to parties she doesn't want me
rifling through all the food looking at
the labels before I leave Lena has had
several severe reactions to peanuts in
the past she says the new treatment has
changed her life Thomas More Sky News